Speaker 1: Well, despite the sunshine
and warmth of the state of Florida,
Ron DeSantis is experiencing significant shrinkage
in the polls, even though he hasn't even announced
that he's running for president in 2024. And
he may not. Ron DeSantis over the last several
weeks has seen a pretty significant decline
in the polls, which we're going to look at in
a moment. Why is this going on? Well, there's an
interesting article in the week by Rafi Schwartz,
and it looks like it looks at a couple of
different aspects to this. And one of the things
that this article mentions, it quotes political
consultant and commentator Simon Rosenberg, who
says that the successes that DeSantis has had in
Florida are actually alienating him from voters in
battleground battleground states, still stinging
from Republican losses by the candidates who
embraced the right most reaches of the political
spectrum. Schwartz writes It's into this dynamic
that DeSantis has, quote, decided to become even
more MAGA Super MAGA. The end result is that
for Republicans hoping to sand, this would be a
reasonable and capable alternative to Trump. This
has been a very bad week. That is one perspective
that actually he is. He is going beyond MAGA.
It's too much MAGA for MAGA and the voters in
battleground states. Aside from whatever Floridian
Republicans say about DeSantis aren't super
thrilled. I think that that's one part of it.
Secondly, the idea of DeSantis was very appealing
as an alternative to Trump. 6 to 8 months ago. But
increasingly, as DeSantis is more publicly
visible, he just was interviewed by Piers
Morgan. We're going to look at clips from that,
his lack of charisma and is complete. We'll leave
it there. His lack of charisma is starting to
become apparent to voters who are sort of being
deflated by that. They were excited about this
and this. Now they've seen what the Santos is
really like and they're like, I don't know, this
isn't really that great. The Hill reports DeSantis
sees lowest level of support since December, and
new poll trails Trump by 28 points. And in fact,
there are a number of polls that are really not
looking good for DeSantis. There is a BBC rated
premise poll which has Trump up 24 with registered
voters. There is a YouGov poll that has Trump up
15. There is a monmouth poll in that has Trump
up 52. Certainly a difficult one to believe,
I have to say, but that's what it says.
A morning consult poll has Trump up 28.
That's the one that was referenced. It's really
not looking good here for Ron DeSantis. So the
question we were previously asking with Donald
Trump was can Trump make it to the primary?
In so far as indictments could derail him or
whatever else might be, the case with the scent is
the question is less about can he make it to the
primaries? It's can he even make it into the race?
Now, I've previously talked about what some of you
have suggested, which is DeSantis is really young.
Why not just wait? Why not just wait until 2028?
He doesn't have to run right now. Trump won't be
a factor no matter what happens in 2028, maybe 48
or 49 year old DeSantis should look at running in
2028. A month ago. My view was he's not going
to be able to look at the polling numbers and
get away because he would be saying to himself,
I might not have this opportunity in 28. As the
numbers decline for DeSantis, maybe 28 starts to
look more attractive. Now what? One other thing.
I would love to say that DeSantis is dangerous.
Authoritarian tendencies are the reason why
he's failing in the polls. But Trump has all of
those same authoritarian tendencies, so that's
not actually what it is. I do think that there is
something to the idea of DeSantis is becoming the
reality of DeSantis, and a lot of people don't
really like it. So Trump, beside DeSantis, is
dangerous. DeSantis is doing better against Biden
than Trump is doing. So in a sense, it's probably
good for the left for DeSantis not to do well in
the primary. On the other hand, DeSantis bailing.
Might make Trump's path easier, which has its own
downsides, in that he may end up in the general
election, less weakened and sort of more ready to
go, but that a lot of things are going to happen
between now and when the general election starts.
So shrinkage for Ron DeSantis. Let's now talk
about a story that is bringing together Trump
and DeSantis, which is very, very interesting.